identifique los ángulos complementarios
y suplementarios en la imagen que se
muestra a continuación y solo para
refrescar la memoria recordemos que los
ángulos complementarios
estos complementarios son los que suman
90 grados y los ángulos suplementarios
son los que suman 180 grados
primero busquemos los ángulos
complementarios vamos a encontrar los
complementarios
dibujamos este ángulo recto marcado aquí
por el ángulo
efe h y está compuesto por dos ángulos
adyacentes que forman un ángulo de 90
grados así que los dos ángulos el f hace
que voy a marcar en otro color este
ángulo el ángulo
efe a c
el otro ángulo que está formado por
h este otro ángulo de acá más el ángulo
formado por c a h son complementarias
pues sus humanos de 90 grados
y estos son todos los ángulos
complementarios
ahora pensemos en los ángulos
suplementarios vamos a escribirlo acá
vamos a encontrar a aquellos que son
suplementarios
los ángulos que suman 180 grados
y el ángulo
a efe este ángulo de aquí que es el
mismo con el que comenzamos en los
complementarios nuestro ángulo
efe efe ac vamos a hacer se a efe
efe y tenemos este otro ángulo formado
por efe ave este otro ángulo de acá
más el ángulo efe a b
estos dos nos van a dar este ángulo
llano de 180 grados por lo que estos nos
van a formar un ángulo suplementario y
el otro par de ángulos suplementarios
son los ángulos formados por c h el
ángulo c
h
este de aquí más el ángulo formado por
los lados h ave por el ángulo formado
aquí más el ángulo h a b esto también
nos va a dar este ángulo de 180 grados y
aquí hemos encontrado todos nuestros
ángulos suplementarios